alex je vous arrête excusez-moi faut je
par je suis très très préc oui vous êtes
un homme très précis puisque à Paris pas
question le samedi vous connait encore
un très grand succès vous avez déjà
commencé un autre film oui vous savez à
cause duéro parce que le métro il faut
pas le rater j'é obligé commencer très
vite ce film s'appelle la grosse caisse
enfin c'est un titre très très
provisoire et dans ce film il y a trois
grandes vaodettes oui Bourville et le
métropolitain Bourville vous avez déjà
fois avec luiou fois paulce c'est prre
la prière fois le mé auss la première
fois M mais je crois que vous n'avez pas
fait une station de métro normale non
c'est St méroon aonstruit à épin parce
que c'est très difficile de le faire
dans le vrai Mét vrai c'est trop
réaliste on l' ici Jacques par qui est
mon décorateur l'a vraiment fait
merveilleusementille
regarder que je
prenne
[Musique]
mais Bourville vous auriez abandonné le
cinéma pour la RATP mais oui parce
que je me suis dit comme j'ai deux
enfants n'estce pas faut penser à Cees
vieux jours
alors il y a la retraite alors depuis
quelques temps je suis au je suis pas
somneur mais vous continuez quand même à
tourner des film en dehors de oui aux
heures creuses qui je des film puis dans
la journée je
poinonne non je vois que vous avez une
très bonne technique j'arrive du Pr coup
je peux vous en faire un autre je suis
un poinonneur qui
écrit un roman policier j'imagine un
hold dans le métro comme je vois chaque
soir la la le train de la caisse qui
passe étant donné ce que je sa
sur sur le convoi j'imagine un
holdup je l'écris à ma façon je le
propose à des éditeurs il n'en veulent
pas il le refuse oui et moi je comptais
sur ce succès de de roman pour céduir à
la petite poissonneuse en face en
l'occurrence
françoiseldic et comme aucun des éiteurs
n'en veut imaginez MAA déconvenu
n'est-ce pas je suis je suis un petit
peu vexé et par dépit je
vais mettre mon mon roman dans la poche
d'un grand
gangster qui a beaucoup d'allure
d'ailleurs qui est paulce
pauluris paul marice vous êtes aussi
dans le métro alors oui les personnages
que j'incarne à l'écran prennent R le
métro mais enfin puisque j'ai l'occasion
d'y rencontrer Bourville c'est pour moi
une occasion que qui me plaît oui car
Bourville vous a remis dans la poche le
manuscrit de son roman qui raconte le
holdop du métro et bien tout le film
tient là-dessus précisément et ce ce ce
film en réalité c'est le déroulement de
l'histoire du roman que Bourville a
écrit alors qu'il voit passer les rames
de métro donc si je me mettais à vous
raconter le le le film je vous
raconterai en même temps le roman mais
si je vous racontais le roman je vous
dévoilerai aussi quel est le film il me
paraît tout de même difficile pour les
spectateurs que je le fasse